so here's a question what are some of
the things you missed and the Deadpool
movie well in this video we're gonna
find out so with deadpool having been
released this weekend if you were one of
the people who happen to see it leaving
out the most obvious references and
easter eggs
what are 27 things you missed firstly in
the slow motion opening sequence is a
cup of coffee with the name Rob Bell
written on it which is a homage to Rob
Liefeld the creator of Deadpool cable
and Vanessa Carlysle in the same
sequence Green Lantern isn't one of the
hindrance wallets and is meant to be
from Ryan Reynolds portrayal of Hal
Jordan in the 2011 Green Lantern film
this sequence also shows a bottle of
Hello Kitty lip balm floating around in
the car which is a reference to the
Hello Kitty Twitter account the only
account that Deadpool follows throughout
the rest of the movie we saw Deadpool
wearing an adventure time watch a
tribute to a popular following on the
Internet involving Deadpool teaming up
with the characters of the series which
focuses on comedy fantasy and adventure
shoot by salt-n-pepa was a common song
in the film because it was released in
1993 the same year that Deadpool
received his first miniseries titled a
circle chase written by Mark Waid while
fighting in the car
Deadpool's head is smashed into the
radio switching the station to the
transition scene from the live-action
Adam West's Batman TV series the street
signs in the opening sequence include
Miss Easy Street and Fabian Road which
is a homage to Fabian miss Issa
co-creator of Deadpool alongside Rob
Liefeld as well as Miller Street
referencing director Tom Miller in
addition to overworked road che hem
circle and silver Avenue which is a
homage to visual effects coordinators
Patrick Thomas O'Rourke to Marcia ham
and scott-heron silver there was also a
parker boulevard since dead bulls often
referred to as being spider-man but with
guns as well as having a long-standing
series of funny moments with the
character an edition of this weasels bar
is called sister Margaret's and is a
reference to a character named sister
Margaret from both the futuristic Marvel
2099 timeline where she led the Howling
Commandos and the main Marvel timeline
where she was the caretaker for
daredevil
following the death of his father when
Wade walks into weasels bar for the
first time someone shouts the phrase
f-fly felled the person who shouted it
was Rob Liefeld himself
during Wade's conversation with weasel
the statement that he became a mercenary
to travel to far-off exotic places meet
new and exciting people and kill them is
actually the exact same quote from x-men
origins Wolverine fat Gandalf is a
reference to a comic book character
named buck Cashman who first appeared in
daredevil number 250 in 1988 who went on
to become a villain named bullet and the
Deadpool comics when Wilson finds out
that he has cancer and to avoid
subjecting Vanessa to the heartbreak of
his death he says that in the next life
he'll stand outside her window with a
boombox a reference to the famous moment
from the 1980s classic say anything
starring John Cusack during the scene
where Deadpool which finished up after
crying he references Liam Neeson's
character from taken in several ways the
reason why this matters is because Liam
Neeson is one of the actors being
considered for the role of cable and
Deadpool - while being taken to the
Weapon X laboratory the subject with
bone fragments bursting out of her body
is marrow a member of the x-men
who uses her bone protrusions as
projectiles and armor when trying to
figure out a Jax's real name
wait guesses the list of increasingly
silly names two of which are Scott and
Bruce references to Scott Summers and
Bruce Banner well the first half of the
movie deals with Deadpool enacting
revenge on all those involved in the
Weapon X program and hunting down Ajax
this is a reversal of the comics where
Ajax had been the one hunting down all
of the previous Weapon X experiments and
killing them leading to his first in
comic encounter with Deadpool
and the scene where Deadpool is
assembling his outfit and tracking down
Ajax
the song playing in the background was
actually created by team headkick
following the release of the Deadpool
video game when Deadpool puts the suit
together the first version which is
all-white is a reference to storm shadow
from GI Joe when introducing blind ow
nipple makes a joke about Robin being in
love with Batman a reference to
allegations that the Golden Age comics
of Dick Grayson and Batman involved
homosexuality
when Ajax an angel does interrogate
weasel in his bar he quits de they
should get to their midnight showing of
blade to a reference to the Gothic style
of the blade series and Ryan Reynolds
appearance in the third movie when
weasel points Deadpool in the direction
of Vanessa after he emerges from the
bathroom
weasel uses the phrase go get her tiger
a phrase used by Mary Jane from the
spider-man comics in the scene when
angel jumps off the Helicarrier her
landing is actually identical to the
landing of Tony Stark and Iron Man to
the x-men costume that negasonic teenage
warhead wears is the same costume that
was created by Grant Morrison during his
run on the series between 2001 and 2004
the henchmen the Deadpool recognizes and
knocks out is actually main Bob a
reference to a character of the same
name from the comics who was an agent of
Hydra and Deadpool sidekick
finally when Colossus says people only
get four or five moments to be a hero
he's actually making a meta commentary
about the number of times Ryan Reynolds
has played and intends to play a
superhero in movies the first was Hal
Jordan with the Green Lantern the second
was Hannibal King from blade Trinity and
the third fourth and fifth came with
Wade Wilson and x-men origins Wolverine
the first deadpool movie and deadpool -
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and if there were any
Easter eggs I left out of here that you
guys think should have been included
feel free to post them down in the
comment section and I will catch you
guys in peace